Oh,
today I want to talk about large scale industrialization and um,
and,
and workers.
Um,
let me say a couple things,
a couple of general points,
um,
that are important.
I is that,
uh,
two things at the beginning,
first of all,
everywhere and particularly in the case of France,
uh,
the industrial revolution was first and foremost a continuation of forms of
production that were already there.
That we've overemphasized the kind of technological advances,
the super inventions of the 18th century in the textile industry.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
even in,
even in in Britain and some of you heard,
we have heard me say this in the context of another course,
a traditional ways of producing things artisinal and domestic industry involving
women,
uh,
doing out work or,
or a domestic industry was essential to the process.
Uh,
the second industrial revolution really,
uh,
it depends on when you want to,
start it up.
I've really,
from the mid 1850s on is more what of the classical kind of way that we've come
to consider large scale industrialization.
That is with no electricity and steel,
uh,
in the other order and large scale units of production.
So that's the,
that's really the first point.
The second point is that for a very long time,
people who did economic history often whom were historian,
I were economics economists,
tended to,
uh,
see,
Britain as,
as this sort of classic case of large scale industrialization.
And,
and,
and even use the,
the most unfortunate word,
retarded,
uh,
when describing a large scale French,
industrialization.
And the reasons they kinda,
they kind of blundered into that,
that,
uh,
kind of analysis that really missed the point is that if you added up,
you know,
the number of,
of factories with x number of,
of workers,
uh,
or if you added up the number of steam engines that,
France,
uh,
lag behind Britain,
but until the mid 19th century,
uh,
Francis,
the second largest industrial economy in the world,
and then gradually overtaken by a Germany and then eventually lapped by,
uh,
by the United States.
Uh,
but it one of the reasons why,
uh,
they,
why did these economic historians argue that,
that France couldn't become,
uh,
you know,
the major industrial leader was that,
that the capital formation was less easily achieved in France because the
banking and insurance facilities were not that,
to be sure of the equal of,
uh,
of Great Britain.
Also,
one of the advantages that England had in a large scale industrialization,
uh,
was this geography,
that you had a,
one of the reasons why the railroad in the world,
uh,
in about 18,
27,
oh,
no,
earlier than that actually,
uh,
about 18,
19,
I guess it is,
uh,
was in England,
north of here is that it was carrying coal down to the sea.
And there's nowhere in England,
this more than 75,
uh,
miles away from the ocean.
Uh,
in France you had,
eh,
the,
the kinds of mind deposits that are so important in,
in the German.
Now I,
you've got them in the north here.
Uh,
you've got them in,
in our,
of course as disappeared.
You have them down in the Soviet home because v and you have them here and there
in other places,
particularly around a Sante Tien,
uh,
but that they are far from,
the,
it's very difficult to transport coal.
And so that was really kind of the problem.
But if you look at large scale industrialization in France,
uh,
it's still proceeds a rather dramatically and in the 18,
but,
but in the French way,
still involving artists,
no pre production craft production in Paris and other cities and still involving
until quite late in the century rural industry.
No,
as a matter of fact,
we just take an example that I always used because I,
I love the,
I love the place.
Uh,
uh,
if you take Ras,
r e m s here,
uh,
industrial production,
it was a major textile center.
You think it has been in Queasy astrical center because the coordination of the
kings and all that business and uh,
the magnificent cathedral,
a rebuilt by the Americans after World War One and the end,
the basilica of San Jaime.
Uh,
but in the 18,
forties and 50s,
you,
well,
18,
thirties and forties,
you still had all sorts of rural industry,
the sort of putting out work into the countryside,
done largely by women.
Uh,
and then gradually you have the growth of large scale industrial production in
the context of factories,
but well into the 1870s,
you still had something like 75,000 embroiderers mostly women.
Again,
living in the hinterland of,
of Nagase and an 1871,
the average unit of production in Paris in Paris was the region was the biggest
industrial center of France,
had only seven people working in it.
So if you're looking for a huge sweatshops,
huge factories that you would find in Manchester and Sheffield and places like
that,
uh,
they were pretty rare in,
um,
uh,
in France and indeed some of the biggest units of production were mines,
by the way.
Uh,
Jimmy now is really about the Ansem minds and they are in the north,
the north of France,
and as that is right,
a couple of kilometers northwest of Valencian,
uh,
so right near,
the Belgian border.
But over the long run that and in into this course,
uh,
the 1850s and sixties,
which is before this course,
but,
uh,
the large scale industrialization is develops more and more,
in France and as in Britain and NSF and other places.
In order to have investment in industry,
you have to have a,
you have to have capital,
you have to have,
uh,
a sort of a surplus of,
of capital and you have to have a way of feeding a growing population only very
slowly in the case of France as you know.
And so there is an increase in production in rural production that makes,
is possible.
A sort of an agricultural,
a revolution,
a that takes place,
uh,
that at certainly has as we'll see in a week or so,
a big problems,
uh,
with the Phylloxera epidemic killing off the vineyards of France,
which is so important to agricultural,
uh,
production,
but you have to eat as well as drink and,
and so there is an increase in,
in production of agriculture all over the place.
And so this is very important.
And just another point,
10 until 10 years ago,
people still talking about the long depression.
And they,
that was a very unfortunate term because it gave the,
the sense that,
that the depression that,
that gripped Europe between 1873,
1874 in the mid 1890s,
was in any way comparable to the Great Depression,
uh,
in industrialized countries and,
and not so industrialized countries.
Uh,
but the industrial,
uh,
depression,
from 1929 in the case of the U S U us doesn't really get out of it until the
massive arms production,
uh,
following the Pearl Harbor,
in,
uh,
and World War Two.
Um,
there it is a,
it's a depression.
Uh,
it,
uh,
you know,
it's characterized by,
uh,
by low prices that you don't have these big sort of catastrophic,
you know,
catastrophic dips.
But,
but it,
it's,
it's a depression which,
which undercuts,
uh,
the economy,
in some way,
uh,
and particularly hurts rural people because the prices of agricultural goods are
so low.
But nonetheless,
if you just,
I mean,
this has,
uh,
this is not economics course,
but it's good to have a few figures in.
Uh,
uh,
nonetheless,
if you look here,
the,
the percentage of the population and working in industry in France in 1876 is
27.6% of the population,
uh,
and,
in 1896,
20 years later is 29.2%.
So,
I mean,
it's quite quite clear.
Pez France is still a peasant society.
Even though many people I have foot in both worlds.
Minors for example,
working in,
uh,
oh in mines,
in,
in the south of France in a place called a cow milk,
which I'll come back to in a while.
A small town in the town.
Uh,
they were both,
uh,
minors end,
agricultural,
uh,
you know,
their farmers and day laborers.
And it's the same thing in other minds,
minds of,
of,
because v,
uh,
but the,
but still the number of people whose,
whose principal activity is industry increases and in France also urbanizes that
at the same time,
now the percentage of the population,
1872 that are urban is 21%,
21.1% or something like that.
In 1901,
it's 40.9%.
They're going to say,
boy,
Francis really urbanized.
But that's completely misleading because,
uh,
to be urban in France as of the census of 1841,
you had to have 2000 people.
And that's all in the example I always give is a 2000 people.
Uh,
you know,
outside the merit and mall when it opens sometimes,
uh,
or the Boston post road mall,
I mean,
2000 people does not seem like a major,
you know,
urban agglomeration.
Uh,
so France,
uh,
still is the level of urbanization is not comparable to that of the Prussian
Rheinland before 1871 or Germany afterward or the United States.
If you go to Neg Naugatuck valley and you know,
this or rust belt there,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the United States urbanizes,
the eastern United States were urbanized as very rapidly.
I mean,
frank,
we'll come back to this when I,
when I talk about cities,
but you know,
France does have large cities above all Paris.
Uh,
but it is primarily an urbanization of very small places of what in French and
in English,
the same word,
or you would call Borg,
B O,U r,
g,
s,
which are market towns essentially.
So small towns.
So,
uh,
we're still dealing with the society,
in which productions overwhelmingly rural,
but in which,
uh,
you know,
France is becoming a major kind of,
of industrial,
uh,
industrial,
producing,
uh,
a producing country.
Uh,
and one of the things that increases the number of people,
I mean,
the earth,
the rate of,
of,
of urbanization.
Urbanization is a growth in the proportional number of people living in whatever
you define as cities,
uh,
is the goal on the pack or the big departure,
as rural people leave,
uh,
leave the countryside and move into cities.
And this is one of the great social happenings of this entire period.
Uh,
and I probably use this artistic for if I didn't,
I should have,
and I'll use it again,
uh,
that in 1851,
1851,
two thirds of all the,
the departments or the pop and France had a larger population in 1851 then they
did in 1939.
So that's really incredible.
So you have really huge growth in the industrial north,
and that's what you've been reading about the na that department in Ord,
uh,
and in other areas with a big major,
center for example,
to lose,
which is,
you know,
the fourth or fifth largest city at that time,
way in the south when a Francis most wonderful cities.
Um,
you,
so you have departments like that,
that are,
that are growing in population because of,
of people leaving the mountains.
People leaving,
uh,
areas of central France is simply aren't we're on top.
I mean,
you can't make enough money to survive,
particularly during an agricultural depression and,
and the wine disease,
we're talking about a catastrophe.
The wine disease,
you know,
knocks out a much production.
I mean,
[inaudible] knocks out the way people live.
Uh,
and in,
you know,
the port in the south and down down in this part of France,
uh,
you already had a huge blow to the rural economy with another disease that comes
along and wipes out,
or at least a severely constraints,
uh,
the silk industry,
the raw silk industry.
So people get up and leave and they go,
ah,
they enter these new jobs like teaching or are clerking,
are working in railroad stations and that transforms the way people live.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
you have to sort of see all of these things that kind of this slow of people
back and forth and,
and even some flows that end.
I mean,
there was since the 16th century,
this pattern of seasonal migration of men,
only men walking,
walking every year,
all the way from this part of central France to Paris to haul two other northern
cities to work in the construction industry.
They started that in the 16th century and they walk every march and then they
come back every,
every,
uh,
November.
And so most babies,
if all goes normally are born within the three months period.
Uh,
and,
but a huge percentage of the,
of the male workforce walks,
uh,
in lines of two all the way to Paris.
It,
it happened.
You also have these patterns from,
uh,
from the Pyrenees down to,
Barcelona and from the Alps down to me law or down to Leon,
those regions to,
and one of the things that happens in this course is that seasonal migrations
stops and those people basically become seasonal migrants.
And the areas from which they came are depopulated.
I mean,
depopulation is one of the most amazing,
uh,
things about rural France.
And that's what it,
it's still,
you know,
what has been going last 10 years has been a rediscovery of the countryside.
And a lot of people retire there.
And you have the phenomenon of which called Biological Twang or sort of
dormitory villages,
uh,
where people live when they're working in the city.
But,
uh,
but one of the astonishing things about,
seeing all the people killed going to the scene,
the war monuments,
particularly in the,
in the [inaudible] trial or places like that,
uh,
is that,
you know,
when you see all these dead people,
you see the,
uh,
you can imagine their faces and you see all their names on these huge plaques,
you know,
80,
90,
a hundred and or just in these little teeny,
you know,
towns in which the countryside has been sort of abandoned and now may be bought
up by the British,
but,
uh,
as in many places,
but so the goal of the path,
the big departure,
uh,
for urban areas and new jobs as part of this entire scene as well.
So where is industrial production in the time we're talking about in France?
Well,
uh,
where's my a little Jiffy statistic?
Uh,
but in,
in the north,
uh,
that is,
certainly the case.
62.1% of the population of people in the na,
uh,
that you're reading about a,
or maybe even finishing this one have already finished this wonderful novel our,
uh,
our,
our workers.
So it's the pure,
so the proletarian they popped him all along with the product la next to it and
the first sort of conurbation a conurbation.
It's cities,
it grows so rapidly.
They,
they all come together like become one city,
uh,
is a leave,
which is all had been there for centuries and centuries.
And then who bay and Truqua,
which just grow up their little Manchester's in France,
you find the same thing around Santa Tien.
So big heavy mining and textile industry in this part of France for sure.
And the other big industrial region of course,
I mean the biggest is the Paris region,
but the Paris region,
you're still producing these articles of Paris.
That's where they call them.
These are to potty,
which are things like wallets and shoes and you know,
find quality goods that are part of the industrial pride of France.
I mean,
when they had these big expositions and in Victorian England,
you know,
that they're all be these,
these mass produce things in,
in England that,
that,
uh,
that William Morris,
you know,
sort of sponsor of arts and craft movement said it was the age of the shotty.
And the French would always proudly say,
we don't turn out this Victorian kind of junk.
We make products of quality.
So you had these fine clothes still being made by pretty put together by single,
by single women or single men.
Uh,
I might have if they're married or not,
but you know,
but working by themselves at home that are part of their artist,
no structure of Paris,
uh,
where if you went into the,
into the hinterland of Paris or into the industrial suburbs,
there you have the dirty industries,
you know,
soap production,
chemical production that,
that people don't want in the city.
And the city values are so high that that if you want space,
you're going to build them outside.
More about that.
When I talk about Paris,
um,
and then you have the young and the old was the silk workers capital of,
of uh,
uh,
really of the world,
in terms of,
of production.
And if you want to find one,
if you're going to go to one city and see where every layer of architecture,
every layer of architecture representing the past is,
is there,
I mean,
Leon was the place to go because they've got Gallo,
Roman ruins.
You've got medieval fabulous medieval,
a neighborhood.
Uh,
you know,
on the right bank of the Stone River,
uh,
you have renaissance quarters,
that are fabulous.
You have,
um,
uh,
you have,
the best 17th century really apartment buildings that are left anywhere.
Uh,
in France you have 18th century sort of classic,
the Plus Belko and you have this 19th century industrial suburb.
We're right on the hill called the Cwa,
who's where all the,
the literally all the buildings have real tall roofs in order to accommodate
these big silk rooms,
which are called jackass.
But you obviously don't have to remember that.
But the point is that this becomes a big industrial center and that even as late
as the 1860s,
you still have merchant capitalists putting work back out into the countryside
in order to take advantage of what of cheap female labor women make one half of
what men do in any trade in Europe.
Uh,
any occupation,
uh,
throughout the 19th century and well into the 20th century.
Um,
that you have other artists know,
kind of producing towns you have,
you know,
to lose as a big artist.
And we'll center,
you know,
Maasais produces soap.
I mean,
I,
I could go through the whole map,
but,
but I'm not going to do that.
You have old textile towns that are still producing,
turning out lots of things like raw,
uh,
just one of my favorite towns,
you know,
in,
in Normandy where I teach,
uh,
every year.
Um,
uh,
of course that we jam and the two weeks,
um,
and trois and places like that.
So these,
but these places are rather a spread apart.
You've got your basic shipbuilding places like San Jose or et Cetera,
et cetera.
So,
um,
though not gifted by having a primary resources near major waterways,
the exception of,
of,
of the lower river,
you still have this transformation of,
uh,
of,
of the economy,
but there is industrial production of some kind,
uh,
almost anywhere that you could go.
And then you have very specialized cases like limos,
uh,
which is famous for his porcelain.
Maybe more about that,
uh,
later.
Why is it famous for his porcelain?
Because there's a clay that you make porcelain out of called [inaudible],
which was a Chinese term,
uh,
that is available there.
And so that's why,
uh,
Havilland porcelain,
which no longer exists incredibly enough.
I've,
you know,
uh,
who was an American,
I said that before,
but at the end,
it doesn't exist if they're closing their other doors and there's only one I
really major producer left.
But these were part of the industrial revolution in,
uh,
in,
love bed,
a frost and I,
and because it has now been a next by Germany that is not now,
but in the 1870s and the,
and,
uh,
I mean 1871 I didn't talk about all the tests production in Alsace,
but there's lots of textile production there.
And as everywhere it's the textile production,
uh,
that is the cutting edge,
the leading edge of the industrial revolution followed by metallurgical
production.
And as in the case of a Britain that is the trains,
uh,
helping encourage investment because people can see trains,
they can ride trains and they look like something that's going to lead France
into this new brave new industrial world.
And so that helps accentuate the number of people who have something to invest,
uh,
investing in,
um,
in,
in railroads.
As a matter of fact,
one of the things that probably hurts French industry,
uh,
during the exactly the period we're talking about that as the 18,
a seventies,
eighties,
and the early 1890s,
is the fact that French capitalists began in,
begin investing in railroads.
But in other places in Italy,
in Russia,
uh,
and in Spain,
where the railroads are,
uh,
to a great extent built by French capital.
So then you've got people who are from English economist saying,
Oh,
well,
they'll never catch up with us because the peasants all hide their money under
their beds,
uh,
or bury them in the gardens.
Or people that have capital to invest are investing the money in,
in these other,
these other railroads.
Now,
um,
what about,
uh,
what about women,
in,
in all of this,
uh,
the role of women in,
you know,
industrial revolution is obviously crucial.
Uh,
in the case of France,
in the case of,
you know,
of Sheffield or on Sheffield or Birmingham and,
uh,
in England,
the role of women in domestic industry or are finishing products,
uh,
was,
extremely important and extremely persistent.
Uh,
the industrial revolution,
even the second industrial revolution does not,
I mean,
the story is more continuity's a then a dramatic changes in,
uh,
the production in the role of women in the industrial revolution.
I mean,
women had always worked in the textile production,
but they'd worked by themselves,
uh,
you know,
in the,
in the von day or,
or anywhere in,
in,
in La Han or almost anywhere,
uh,
back for centuries.
And they still do,
uh,
we've exaggerated,
the separation of work and home,
uh,
in the role of women in the industrial revolution.
Because if you look at Paris and the 1890s,
I have a former graduate student,
Judy coffin.
It was a wonderful book on the sewing machine and its role in all of this.
If you look at industrial production of these fine garments and handbags that
are made in Paris,
many of them in the garment industry,
the garment district of Paris,
which is right in the,
in the center of Paris on the right bank,
around a street called salt ta are done by single women working on in the very
top floors by themselves and working for a merchant capitalist just as their
predecessors had done,
uh,
you know,
two centuries before that.
And so those continuity's are still very important.
But to be sure,
you know,
in,
in the more sort of classic or,
uh,
you know,
the usual kind of thing you hear.
I mean,
I'm making a while to be sure they gradually move into factory,
uh,
production.
Uh,
but what does not change is the,
another thing is not changes the role of women in the managing of the household
economy because women have to somehow piece together a enough work I enough,
you know,
enough income from their children and from other husbands or partners in order
to keep the family going.
Uh,
and women's role in,
uh,
the industrial and the household economy,
is still a extraordinarily important.
Also,
some aspects of women worked at his nonindustrial does not change,
uh,
in England,
in,
in Great Britain.
But let's say England in 1850,
and again in 1880,
the largest,
uh,
to female occupations are textile operatives,
factory workers and domestics.
Uh,
and in France that's the same case too.
And one of the things that d that single women do who come into Paris or legal
or [inaudible] or whatever to try to get a job is they placed themselves in
domestic service.
Uh,
and of course their conditions of work are our lamentable.
And there's,
although an often,
often,
and there's a whole range of literature you know,
about,
you know,
about what happens to them.
And of course the,
the,
some of the most spectacular,
uh,
um,
cases of,
of things going wrong are the ones that you hear about from,
from social commentators at that time,
which is,
you know,
the single,
a domestic servant service gets impregnated by the,
you know,
by the aggressive older son or younger son of the boss.
And then the minute she is pregnant,
she is out of there.
And then,
uh,
that is a fairly quick road in many cases of many rural people to,
if they can't,
if you are pregnant,
you're not going to get hired.
Who's going to hire you?
So then what happens to the baby in France,
anywhere,
infanticide or abandonment in the foundling homes,
uh,
and uh,
what they did.
And so,
so in order to cut down the infanticide rate,
they create this thing and it still was debated again about three months ago in
Rome.
They create these things called tour.
Well,
I mean,
I don't know you to,
you know,
their tool,
they,
these things that turn,
uh,
and they're liking machines that they used to have in the ill fated machine
city,
which some of you don't remember,
uh,
were,
you know,
you put in your money and if you get lucky,
you know the product will actually come back towards you.
And what happens there is you ring a little bell on this little thing turns and
you put the baby in there.
Uh,
and then,
then some nice person keeps the baby cause otherwise you just abandon the baby
and the baby dies.
And the number and fantasize every day was tragic.
And once you got in,
if you were a baby and you get in one of these funneling homes,
your chances of survival are very sin.
Uh,
in every large foundling home are really into the eighth through the 1870
[inaudible].
The number of people have babies who,
who die is one third every year.
So,
um,
that's another reason by the way,
why,
why French cities?
Uh,
you know,
more people die in French cities that are born in French cities through much of
the century because of the huge rates of child abandonment and in fantasize.
Uh,
so it's,
uh,
you know,
it's a most unfortunate scene.
And then what happens after a x,
you know,
this mother x has her baby abandoned her baby,
and sadly maybe in 10% of the cases kills her baby.
Uh,
is that uh,
the road to prostitution,
uh,
is,
is a rather,
um,
rather quick one coming along,
uh,
or tried to get back into a domestic service.
So,
um,
but you know,
for,
for most,
for most women,
things go better than that though.
They never go splendidly cause they're never going to get,
earn what males work earn.
And they're the first,
the last hired and the first fired right along.
And then you had this other thing that happens is that the Socialists are quite
concerned with what happens to,
to women's wages.
And the unions are quite concerned what happens to women wage women's wages,
but they're not really concerned about it whether they have the right to vote.
Why?
Because the Socialists afraid that because women,
as I said before,
I'm more apt to go to church that than men by far then and now that they will
vote the way the priest tells them in the confessional.
So the Socialists do not support the right of women to vote.
And women of don't vote in France.
They don't get the right to vote after World War One,
despite all the sacrifices.
They get the right to vote in Britain,
they don't get the right to vote in France until after World War Two.
So,
um,
again,
so,
so what,
what,
what changes to keep your eye on the big picture is that domestic industry
gradually implodes into,
into the cities,
into factories on the edge of,
of,
uh,
French cities,
big and small.
But that what women do doesn't change.
They're still doing domestic industry.
They're still doing,
um,
uh,
I mean,
they're still doing textile work.
They're not doing domestic industry.
Take that back.
I take that back,
they are doing,
uh,
textile industry work,
but increasingly in factories,
which is the classic,
uh,
the classic,
you know,
portrayal of the industrial revolution.
And so the classic betrayal ends up being right but only rather gradually in
France over a very long period period of time or take caffeine.
One of the more engaging figures in,
in uh,
in modern French literature.
I think it's fair to say her experience is perfectly normal.
Uh,
it's sad.
It's pathetic,
but it's very normal.
Um,
give me an example.
This is,
um,
uh,
you know,
we don't,
we live about two and half hours from Santa Tana and I heard they were going to
Santa Tiana,
go to their work once in a while in the archives,
but not that often.
Um,
nor do I follow the van,
which is there,
there a famous,
uh,
a soccer team,
but there's still an expression that people use their,
if a child screws up,
does something,
you know,
you're nine or eight or nine years old,
use something your parents tell you not to do and you do it anyway.
They'll say something like,
uh,
do cement [inaudible] Ben to two weeks under a,
Ben is a kind of a wagon that's used to haul coal and what children did in
factories and in minds is because they're small.
You can put them under one of these wagons and they help move it along the
tracks.
That'd be a lot of fun,
wouldn't it?
Because they have little shoulders,
but strong shoulders or,
uh,
you know,
or,
uh,
you know,
fixing machines in factories with their little fingers,
which would get chopped off there.
So careless said a British manufacturer when a couple of them kept getting their
fingers chopped off.
Um,
and so a way of correcting,
you know,
a child,
we say two weeks,
we will push and that thing around and you won't screw up.
You'll do what I tell you to do.
Uh,
you know,
you won't skip school.
You'll go to school and this sort of thing.
So these expressions still linger.
So child labor too,
again,
I mean,
there is opposition to schooling from families who need that extra income or
that extra labor of children,
uh,
in the farm yard.
Uh,
or watching the sheep and the transhumanists,
uh,
moving the sheep into the mountain and all that.
So the,
these again,
these continuity's and changes are,
uh,
extremely,
um,
uh,
extremely,
important.
Now.
Um,
I didn't,
and I don't think I have time to do this now,
but I'll do it some time to talk about the decline of the French population.
Why France simply stops having children.
I've talked a little bit about that,
but I have to come back and do that again.
I think I'll wait till we're talking about,
uh,
about the origins of World War One because that's when it really frightened
people,
uh,
because it didn't look like there'd be no French to survive,
to,
uh,
maybe fight a war against all those rapidly breeding Germans.
Uh,
and things weren't working there.
So what I want to talk to about now is how workers viewed what was happening to
them.
Um,
and so there's really kind of three things I want to say.
The first is,
is quick is,
is that proletarian [inaudible] is both an,
and this was a word that people used was,
is both an objective and a subjective concept.
Uh,
and the third is to talk about how workers viewed the factory and viewed their
bosses because the period,
particularly 1895 to 1907 has been called the heroic age of syndicate realism or
union organization and strikes in France.
Now Proletarian Ization uh,
we live in a country in which a part of the Canon is always been that,
uh,
that in in America,
if you work hard,
you'll always be rewarded at the end.
And that,
that,
uh,
that the descriptions of,
of the late 19th century is that the people working very hard and doing very
well and moving into the middle and the upper classes and becoming very wealthy.
Uh,
obviously that's not the case.
that the,
the great exceptions where the one that people paid attention to there is social
mobility in France or used to be all sorts of studies.
That's what people did not mean.
But in the,
in the,
in the 1970s about social mobility,
but social mobility was,
uh,
was extremely limited for people who were born into,
um,
into their working class.
Uh,
and in 1968,
1968,
the riots de la revolutional monkey in 1968,
one of the big issues that students your age had and professors my age had a
though I was your age then,
or a little younger I guess,
uh,
was that,
you could work your ass off,
um,
and your chances of getting into a university weren't very good because once you
were born into,
you know,
the lower classes,
uh,
the schools where we're schools of elites,
that's what they were.
And once you got through there,
there was no guarantee you're going to get a job anywhere.
And people were extremely mad and upset and they,
they viewed,
they blame capitalism.
They blame the state,
uh,
as people.
Their predecessors had an in the 1890s,
uh,
and so people who were born into a life of work,
a life of hard,
difficult work,
uh,
that was one,
you know,
you ended up,
you were born into,
into the jobs that you would get a,
and if,
I'll give you another San Antonian example because it's so important.
Senate Tien,
uh,
that there are lots of people who moved to Santa Tn.
Don't have to remember this come from a very religious part of France called the
law of which the capitalist loop,
we,
and a lot of these,
these,
these people emptying out,
that department moved to Santa Tien and they don't move.
You know,
some of them become teachers,
some they're going to get clerks jobs if they're educated,
but they don't do very well.
Uh,
and they live that,
you know,
there are periods where they're doing all right and then they're let go and then
they're doing all right.
And then they're let go.
And it's just the more you read about about 18,
uh,
80s and 90s,
and sort of memoirs of working people was just the difficulty of,
of making things work from a day to day,
week to week,
month to month,
just getting by.
And they learned to hate.
I,
I'm a writing a book about a guy who will tell you about some day who really,
he said that love can make you hate.
And,
and he,
he viewed all of this and then he set out to destroy the state that he thought
had made capitalist impossible.
But that's another story for another day.
So,
you know,
there's this objective statues status of,
of being,
you know,
you're,
you're a worker.
That's what you do and you're proud of it.
And you were blue as a color.
Uh,
you wear your blue,
you know,
frock,
her smock,
whatever you call it.
Uh,
and you spoke a language in our goal read.
you know,
if you read a law somewhere,
in France,
I mean,
it's a,
it's a language that's extremely difficult to read because a lot of the
expressions have disappeared.
But it's a,
it's a way of protecting your identity.
Uh,
it's like the way people talked in the suburbs,
particularly in the 19 century,
1980s,
1990s on very long.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a kind of language,
kind of an are of a slang and our goal that helps protect your identity,
that you're proud of your identity.
And you know,
they were proud of being workers as well.
They should.
But the subjective aspect is what people studied in the 1960s and seventies.
And the term is class consciousness.
And certainly there was an attempt to prove that all workers all over the place
where class conscious,
but that wasn't the case.
People have other identities,
collective identities.
You can have multiple identities,
family,
religion,
uh,
region.
We've talked about this village,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But the fact remains that one of the reasons why there's so many strikes in
France as another country's too,
uh,
it has to do on one hand with unionization and the sympathetic role of,
of left wing politicians in supporting,
uh,
working class organization.
But it has also as much to do with people coming to a sense that they are
workers and are conscious of themselves as a class,
and they view this state and the wealthy people as being contrary to their
interest.
Now,
this starts in France,
starts in earlier among artisans in,
in Britain,
and arguably in the 1790s in France.
It really starts in the nineties and the eighties,
the 1830 [inaudible].
And the word socialism was first used by a socialist.
Uh,
uh,
in 1834,
a guy called Pierre [inaudible] who was a utopian socialist,
uh,
forgetting.
Um,
but he's,
he's an interesting guy.
Um,
but it's at this point where artisans,
not ordinary workers but see themselves as a class apart though at the beginning
they'd want it anything to do with these unskilled workers that they may work
with under,
in a factory,
but they're dressed nicely.
They were a quarter ray suits.
And these other workers,
they don't dress like that and they're educated.
That's why artisans are at the forefront.
They create the strike really,
uh,
in the early modern period.
It's artisans,
it's skilled craftsmen.
And just in two minutes,
why does this happen?
What,
why to artisans suddenly start seeing themselves as a class apart?
Why do they start targeting capitalism as a structure,
uh,
and the state as doing them a injustice?
Why?
Well,
they're really two reasons that that one can give.
Uh,
one is that what happens because of the French revolution to craftsman in
Germany,
in parts of Italy and in France,
uh,
is that that it opens the doors and the guild protections are gone.
Anybody can be any trade you want laissez faire,
capitalism.
You want to be a plumber,
you can be a plumber,
you want to be a tailor,
you can be a tailor.
And so all of a sudden in the,
in Paris and the 1830s,
forties,
and 50s,
there's all sorts of wagons being pushed through the street with beautifully
made clothes on him going for practically nothing.
Uh,
because there's so many other tailors making suits and the price,
the wages these guys get.
Marx was right about only about that.
And so far as his assessment of,
of wages,
artisans are making less money.
Their world is falling apart.
They have the dignity,
they have the skill,
they have the knowledge,
they have the organization in friendly societies,
which at a minimum give you a decent burial is you're not dumped into some prop
operas grave.
And they're mad because who let all these other people do the trades,
the guilds had protected.
And the other thing that happens is it goes back to where we started
industrialization and mechanize production that if you go to a market in a
class,
since they used that example before or anywhere you want in Oh banal or provide
an impulse,
Ooh,
you can go there and you can buy a suit off the rack.
You can just go and buy a suit and you don't have to pay somebody a lot of money
to make your suit from getting to the end.
Um,
so because,
and it's cheaper.
So who does that hurt?
It hurts the artisans,
the craftsmen.
And so what happens then?
Uh Huh.
Somebody with money says,
Hey,
you guys are all Taylor's,
you're not doing so well.
Are you?
Things aren't real good.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
I will pay you to make pants cuffs.
I don't know much about suits.
As you probably gathered,
I will tell you to make pants,
pants,
cuffs.
I make you make pants,
cuffs,
I guess you have to.
Or to make sleeves on a jacket.
And all I want you to do is make it a hundred sleeves on a jacket.
You make the left ones,
you make the right ones and I'll pay you.
It's just like domestic industry before.
Are they mad?
Of course they're furious and they s they go out and strike,
but they always did.
They lose.
And you can strike in France after 1864.
So that's what happens to them.
Or let me give you another example from,
from good old Lee Moje.
Uh,
in Limos,
uh,
you,
you know,
plates you take,
you got plates and plates had always been beautiful plates had been hand
painted.
[inaudible]
the painter,
he started life as a,
as a,
as a porcelain painter.
And then,
and that's what made it a quality item.
If you can,
if you find painted Limoges plates from the 1880s,
you hang on to those babies and don't put them in the microwave.
Uh,
so then what happens with somebody invents a process where you can put like a
decal on a child's toy onto the plate and bake the decal onto the plate between
the first and second baking.
So what happens is these people who are very talented who made all this money
and didn't hang around,
you know with these other guys who make less money,
they are screwed.
No one's going to hire them.
We'll keep one or two.
I went to a special order that had been done for the Shah of Iran.
This was a long time ago,
hand painted cause he wanted to hand painted but that's the end of that.
And they ended up in their warehouse or ended up doing whatever they could or
glass workers.
The same thing.
The people that that made bottles were very skilled and they were called
[inaudible].
They were called the Mr a glass worker.
And suddenly somebody United States invents a machine that can make glasses.
I'm a bottles,
turn out,
thousands of them be filled with wine and other things.
Who needs these guys anymore?
And they'd go on the road to Belgium or where they can't.
Nobody needs somebody any more machine is eliminated them are they mad ho and
shoemakers.
The same thing these machines made in Saint Louis,
Missouri I think come along and wipe out,
you know,
certain aspects of shoemaking.
So this is leads people to think there are something that we can't control out
there that is affecting our lives in a very ruinous way.
So these people are at the forefront of labor militancy.
And in the course of the 1880s and 1890s,
they start thinking about,
hey,
you know,
those people that we don't drink with,
the ones who load of things carry things around.
Ordinary workers maybe,
you know,
maybe they got the same,
maybe the same enemy,
and then they start supporting,
they're hesitant,
organizational movements and strikes and they,
uh,
they get together.
Now how did this look from the point of view of,
you know,
of,
of workers,
how do they view what was happening to them?
You know,
again,
we can romanticize class consciousness.
We can remat assize this idea of a moral economy that people ought to be paid,
uh,
for a good wage,
for a good day's work.
Uh,
and it didn't happen all over the place,
but still it's rather a rather impressive and,
and,
and depressing,
uh,
impressive the organization and depressing the view of,
of capitalism and the factory is these units of production,
uh,
get larger and larger.
Let me give you two examples how this look,
one during strikes.
What was the image that workers had of their bosses?
And what does this tell us?
And My,
my,
uh,
friend and cherish colleague,
one of the greatest stories I've ever known,
one of the great people I've ever know,
knowing Michelle pet ho in France and did,
uh,
did work on this among other Virgina,
sees,
uh,
works,
um,
uh,
the view of the other in the 1820s and 1830s,
when artisans went on strike,
you know,
they knew the boss,
the master,
and the wasp was somebody who,
you know,
they'd see and all that.
And they seem around,
but they're,
they're kind of mad at him.
So we're going to withdraw our labor for awhile.
We don't,
you know,
uh,
you got to pay us more.
You know,
you gotta be the guy you can be,
you ought to be the guy you can be in pay us adjust wage.
Well the master,
you know,
he has pretty good relations with them.
He May,
uh,
you know,
like the,
the,
the like the Noble Inn in to lose.
He me around to news.
He may give them a,
you know,
a chicken and Easter or something like that,
but he,
somebody recognizable and he's paternalistic,
but this time he's gone wrong.
So we're going to go out on him,
will blacklist them and all that.
What about the 1850s and 1860s?
Why that is very different indeed.
They 1850s in 1862 if you look at the vocabulary of people on strike that they,
that,
you know,
they still know the boss,
they say to the boss,
uh,
but they call them a latch.
He's alleged cause he hits on is a female work or something often with,
with some success.
Uh,
he's a,
uh,
you know,
he's,
he's gross or eats too much or he drinks too much or a beats his wife,
their personal characteristics,
uh,
in the kind of language,
the gesture,
the gestures and the lot power,
the discourse of strikes.
And what about the 1890s and the first decade of the 20th century.
It's transformed completely,
particularly in big factories because something has come along to change the way
people view their own work experience.
And this is called industrial discipline,
industrial discipline.
And this,
the strikes then the boss is often in Paris sending telegrams to the Moje saying
how they should deal.
They being the foreman,
deal with the workers.
He be kids become a symbol of capitalism,
defended by the army of the state in the of militant,
uh,
send the Coulis militant union people who had the right after 1881 to organize.
He is a symbol of this,
the structure of a large scale industrialization that they can't control.
And he is off,
you know,
in the Chateaux on his boat.
And Normandy or something like that.
But he has been,
the voice of him is now the foreman and the foreman enters the game and are,
is not the game,
uh,
but enters the workshop and he represents the intense to impose industrial
discipline on people whose parents or even them.
It always worked at home and you worked when it was light or you worked when you
had done nursing your baby,
then you worked and when you wanted to go for a stroll to have a smoke or have a
drink,
you did that.
But the foreman puts up up regulations that you will be fine.
If a plate is broken,
you'll be fine for chattering.
There was a horrible fire in Brooklyn.
They killed them.
140 women had been sort of locked in in about 1910 or 1911 because they were
chattering.
They're going out in the back to instead of working in talking and so they all
burned to death and the regulations told them that you will be fine if you do
this,
you'll be fired if you do this.
And the person that enforces them is the foreman.
The foreman is promoted from within or increasingly brought from the outside to
impose industrial discipline on these workers,
that Wedgewood pottery manufacturer.
Some of you heard of that.
He once said very prophetically in 1807 or 1808,
he said,
what I want to do is I want my workers to be like hands,
who move and who act and who react to the commands of my brain and they will do
what I want them to do.
So the factory,
and this is in England too,
is you know,
if you can think of assembly lines,
I used to work at Kellogg,
so Battle Creek,
I did the raisin bran.
I put the raisins into snap,
pop into snack pack.
You know,
I did that and I worked at Ellis loves jams and jellies and Portland,
Oregon,
uh,
and all this.
And we hated the form.
And I'll tell you that we just hated them.
So at least I could hate them.
I hate them,
but I did hate them.
I'm sure I hated them.
Chris.
We hated them.
But you're,
but it's a format or the people who put the regulations up,
who punish you for trying to be yourself,
who trying to leave to see your friends.
And then the form.
They create these factories as a way of imposing industrial discipline when you
see,
and that's not the only reason cause you need factories for big machines.
These machines,
I can never forget it,
how to work them.
Uh,
in a,
I worked in a canning plant,
I could never,
I suppose to work this machine,
I can never figure out how to work in.
It would get jammed all the time and I'd always get in trouble.
So that's me.
It is all coming out now.
But what they do is they create,
they create,
when you have workers wanting to have their pictures taken,
when you have cameras,
you know,
and when they're taking their pictures together,
like a football team or like a baseball team,
they're always in front of the door of the factory.
Why?
Because they're very few doors and there's a clock over the door and is now the
clock.
It's the siren that tells you when you can come and go,
not when you're hungry.
Now,
when you're a baby needs to be nursed,
uh,
not when you just had to hear what breathing,
dust and know you're going to get TB and Croak from that,
uh,
in lots of places.
And that's what imposes this industrial discipline,
uh,
comes from,
you know,
from these,
these,
these foremen.
And so strikes are often against form.
And there was a strike in the motion of women.
Workers were forced to kneel down and pray before the workday and they strike
against women form.
And to now,
not all of them were egregious,
but nonetheless,
this was a way of them,
you know,
of way of viewing.
Their experience was shaped by the necessity of being at one place at one time.
And if you're not there,
see Ya,
that's the end of that.
Uh,
you better be there and imposed industrial discipline inside.
the workplace.
I did a film for a documentary for,
um,
FTL trois on,
on,
uh,
on the Moje,
on the,
on the strikes in 1905.
And we did part of his 100 degrees,
literally this 41.
And we did it.
We did it in the,
in the ruins of the Hablan factory with dead pigeons and plates.
And the door wasn't there anymore.
But I'd seen it before.
And you could feel what it meant to these people if they had their pictures and
they said goodbye to comrades who had been fired,
who had been let go because there wasn't enough money,
it was pretty bad.
So the industrial discipline,
uh,
Jen,
you know,
it attempt to create this kind of perfect workforce.
What it does is it creates resentment and it helps explain,
uh,
there are other reasons too,
but this kind of mobilization of ordinary people.
Now let me just finish with the following story cause this is an amazing thing
in a few of you in other courses have heard this,
but I tell because it's just talk.
It was prophetic.
It was again,
this wonderful story and historian Michelle pit hole.
When she wrote an article,
I published it in a collection of essays.
Long time we will call the,
uh,
the three ages of industrial discipline.
And at court parallels the,
the view of the other,
uh,
where you know,
you're against,
uh,
the guy's trying to pay the patrons,
trying to get you another potholes,
trying to get you to produce this plate and this,
this stuff and these shoes and all of that.
And then pretty soon as the form,
and it tells you how many things you're going to do.
But when,
what happens in the 1900 at a time when the Olympic start and you're counting
how far or restart,
how quickly you can run the hundred meters or whatever,
and they,
they,
uh,
an engineer called Taylor Taylorism and American comes up with a way of
measuring productivity by counting the units that you can produce you how many
little,
little God awful bags of a,
of a boxes of,
of raisin brand.
Uh,
you know,
could I produce in,
in so many hours and they count them.
And if you don't count enough,
no,
you're out of there.
If you,
if you don't,
you don't have enough.
We weren't unionized and we couldn't be unionized them.
Uh,
you're out of there.
And what happens,
you know,
that I know Taylorism becomes very important.
Ford loves Taylorism.
Uh,
and,
and the car producers Renaud embraces Taylorism.
It's just an unbelievable thing.
And there's the one started going to a tailor or some French engineer comes to a
American company and says,
uh,
well,
although all the workers or young here,
this was a tailor is in place.
All the workers are young.
We're the old ones.
He says,
come on along.
We'll have a smoke in the cemetery.
And you'll see,
and Michelle Po a said predicted in ne in 1978 that,
that the kind of surveillance or the kind of,
uh,
the kind of counting of the assembly line production would give way to what she
called in an amazing thing.
I think about our postindustrial world of the cubicles of people answering phone
calls and doing computer line work will give ways the way you measure
performance and create industrial discipline will give way to what she called
beautifully the quiet violence of the computer.
And it did see on Wednesday.